we have this clip here from Tucker as
well
Vivek tweeted a clip I want to play for
you guys I'll just play it you know my
parents came to this country with almost
no money
I've gone on to found multi-billion
dollar companies and then people tell me
oh that's because you had privilege
they tell me white privilege it's sort
of weird it's sort of an interesting
it's kind of interesting do you tell
them
it's like it's great I said take the
blindfold off
but the interesting answer is actually
what I do tell them Tucker is that I did
have privilege
I didn't grow up in money
but I had two parents in the house a
mother and a father with a focus on
education and a faith in God and you
know what that is the ultimate privilege
that if I'm going to enjoy that every
kid in this country
ought to enjoy it too
so we have from that clip and the reason
I wanted to play it is I'm going to
refresh for you right now the prediction
markets for the GOP Presidential
nomination which currently has Vivek
ramaswamy at 13 cents Rhonda stands at
15 and Trump at 62 Trump the clear
FrontRunner let's refresh and see where
we're at and the fake has dropped down
by one cent Rhonda centers has gone up
by one cent these things are very much
in flux considering uh these clips are
still going around right now but Vivek
ramaswamy is has skyrocketed I mean if
we take a look at this let's go to 90
days in the prediction Market take a
look at this he's jumping he is climbing
the ranks DeSantis is dropping down
rather quickly I do think and again
these are not polls but I think the
people who are tracking the political
landscape who are making bets on what is
gonna uh what the outcome is going to be
I think we're very close to seeing Vivek
ramaswami take second place relatively
soon
I think that like what like what the Vic
said uh at the very end like I'm an
agnostic and I agree with him oh hands
down yeah the clip was fantastic yeah
absolutely
um and nightly privilege that's why he's
advancing in the polls like this because
he speaks I think that he speaks in a
very
um authentic way he doesn't sound like a
politician I don't think or at least he
doesn't come across like a politician to
people because he does sound very
polished but I don't feel like he's
just delivering the the a narrative kind
of line
um and maybe that's my own personal
opinion because I've I'm rather
I find his his
arguments compelling I like listening to
him yeah I think all his arguments are
compelling I just everything he is uh he
wants to dismantle the government in
various pieces and I think what he says
a lot is some smart Solutions so I'm
happy that he's getting this out to get
a little bit more name recognition and
I'm surprised that DeSantis has fallen
so much but you know he has so much
negative attention now that I mean with
with Disney whether you're right or
wrong it is anti-cannabis whether that's
right or wrong he's just kind of like
just just driving into the ground
yeah you know look
don't ask me why you know I've got my
opinions on on these things but uh what
I've been saying to many descent
supporters is just look at the
prediction markets in the polls he's
going down okay that is not for me
wanting it to happen I think he's he's
an excellent leader who really has his
ear to the ground on all these issues
but I think he's doing a very terrible
job campaign-wise but even if you think
I'm wrong I just I'm curious why he's in
this decline
if you ignore it it'll only get worse
yeah and his wife's a a a perfect
running mate for him like she's she's
out
um she's well polished and so she she's
adding I think a lot of value but then
at the same time he's obviously crashing
not enough value what do you guys want
uh I would libertarian libertarian well
you're libertarian too man uh Vivek and
RFK made it I I feel like the America
wins to just uh just to voting why RFK
though I'm a big fan of him just uh well
well he's got a big long history of very
authoritarian positions this is a vow
disavow no I you know here's what I
would say personally
for the Democrat leadership he's the
best they got yeah because with all his
bad policies he's better than all the
rest way better you know so I would love
to see that but and so for me it's kind
of like uh I'm I'm not a big al
libertarian libertarian party kind of
guy I'm actually more like fairly
liberal on the political Spectrum so I
look at an RFK Junior like you know I
think he's really trying to be a
populist he's really trying to reach the
people and uh he's speaking about a lot
of uh current issues that are good so we
we've talked about the power of like a
trump Kennedy ticket but uh I don't want
to ask you about Republicans because you
know you're a Libertarian is there is
there a liberty is there someone you
want to see Run for the libertarian
ticket uh I've seen a couple people who
are running for the libertarian ticket
but yeah I don't quite feel that they're
quite ready in the task huh who's
announced for the Libertarians Chase oh
Chase is from uh from uh Georgia right
yeah yeah okay Chase Oliver yeah uh
Chase Oliver yeah I believe he's
announced
um but yeah I mean I know who he is I
followed him in the Georgia election I
know where he got his Spotlight from
with the whole uh senate election but
you know Shane Hazel did it the year
before I did it same year as Shane Hazel
did in North Carolina you know getting
three percent and breaking the uh the
barrier and you know switching the
election it happens every year somewhere
along the line and that's really kind of
what he's writing I don't really know
enough about him I don't agree with them
on
some of the uh qia issues the LGBT you
know yeah which kind of Chase yeah yeah
you know Libertarians tend to really
agree with each other you know yeah you
know a lot of them just say uh you know
yeah many things aren't good but at the
same time we live in a society where you
just can't run amok
yeah I love I love that Meme though with
groundskeeper Willie and he's like
Libertarians they ruined libertarianism
I mean the the first thing that or the
best way to know that you're an actual
libertarian is another libertarian says
you're not a real libertarian that's
right that's it you know yeah we're
stuck we're getting into it right now I
know a lot of people said out so early
we're only a few weeks in for a lot of
these candidates but uh this is where
the pickup happens because the primaries
are coming I think what March yeah of
next year so that's gonna be a big deal
it is a very very big deal historically
that Joe Biden is even facing a primary
as the incumbent with one more term
available to him that's surprising I
don't I mean it's I think that it's
surprising that there are people that
are kind of speaking up but at the same
time it's also surprising that he's
actually the president because he's it's
really clear that he's not the guy
running the show he's a puppet yeah I
mean we've got it's run by the the
bureaucracy bureaucracy and it's not Joe
Biden that's making the calls I mean
he's a perfect candidate for him yeah
but not anymore no I mean in the future
because he's not in charge yeah I wonder
if the the reason they ran Biden was
because they feared prosecution
if uh if Trump won Biden's in trouble
yeah if any other Democrat won Biden
doesn't have any control and may get
thrown to the bus so let's say 2020 you
know let's just say hypothetically
Newsome gets elected for all his faults
and problems
when stories start breaking about
Biden's their corruption say these
stories out of like Politico that came
out you know almost 10 years ago
new you know any other Democrat might be
like look we're not going to sacrifice
the future of our administration because
the mistakes and the problems you
encountered I do think they'd still
probably protect him but he would not
have the power of the presidential seat
to protect himself so I wonder if a
large component was uh oh Trump started
looking into what we were doing in
Ukraine we better
we better get Biden in so we can put an
end to this because that's really was
the big issue Biden did not announce he
was running for president Trump calls
Ukraine and says hey what's up with this
video they then claim in the media
Donald Trump was digging up dirt on his
political opponent as if the only thing
they could have done has been like uh
he's running for office hey you can't do
that you can't you can't look at these
crimes and then now he's got to run for
office you know what I mean and Democrat
media establishment fell in line right
away and started immediately Shifting
The Narrative that direction yeah I mean
that that was gonna go as soon as soon
as there was someone that was
establishment approved the the media was
going to go all in anyways uh that that
there wasn't a whole lot of question
about that who's going to be Now is it
going to be like Newsome I mean
overwhelming the prediction markets are
saying Joe Biden
it is interesting seeing the way that
like the fact that there's any
competition at all kind of proves that
if you're not paying close attention you
wonder how that could possibly be
because if you're not paying close
attention you just assume he's doing a
great job you don't know what's actually
going on in the world but if there's any
competition at all it does prove that
there is a bit of a dent in the armor
there and it's hard for the average
person to see but just even hearing
about an RFK if you're somebody that
doesn't pay close attention to politics
I would hope that would at least wake
them up and be like why is there anyone
even questioning this at all you could
actually I guess mention his age would
be a big part of it like a lot of people
even if they're not politically uh
initiated might wonder why is a guy his
age going to be running again Trump's
Trump's very old as well yeah what what
is what is 75 a year younger than Biden
he just doesn't show it no way he's more
than these years yeah yeah he's four
years four or five or four or five like
he will be the same age like he would
have been the same age at the next
election that fighting was when he got
elected and and I think what was RFK
he's 69 or 70. yeah he's like 69 or 70.
we need some younger people I I can
absolutely understand
Vivek yeah if it makes what 38 yeah
maybe 37 he's young uh but Ron DeSantis
too I certainly understand that but I
gotta tell you man if Ron is hurting
this much in the polls and they're not
course correcting I I think that's a
failure of leadership I think I love his
policy I think the reason Iran is is
kind of tanking is because Ron doesn't
have the Charisma people thought that he
was going to have like when he gets onto
the onto the national stage people
aren't like he's not magnetic when he's
on stage he doesn't have the Charisma
he's not he's not like uh uh Barack
Obama he's not Bill Clinton he's not
Donald Trump and those are three people
that had really really significant
Charisma and you there's an argument
that uh that bush had really good
Charisma as well so that could be it but
the a big part of that is people like
the idea that he was more stoic in that
he could be a version of Trump without
without being more bombastic and that
was the top but that doesn't work once
you actually have to come out and speak
more regularly just because that was an
argument doesn't mean that was actually
what the the country was going to feel
yeah you know what I mean so it's and
I'm just saying that this is this could
be I don't know but it would make sense
that the more people
and get exposed to him and hear him
speak at outside of just in the context
of Florida the less they actually like
him when he when he when he felt like
because I'm just I'm not paying as close
attention to that as I as I was before
but when somebody mentioned like his
stance on weed I'm like really really
like even if that is your stance why are
you talking about it now why wouldn't
you hold off and just not mention it
like it just it seems like a
disconnection there are still
Republicans that like that you know well
we can talk about uh the viability of
the Republicans and uh there will be
more developments of course maybe Rhonda
santis will shift some of his campaign
really so to take off it is early
there's a lot of opportunity for him
there thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time